hey everyone how you doing hello Morgan
I'm doing great so this is one of the
most impressive casts I've ever seen in
a movie you even have Taylor Swift in
this film Marco what was this whole
experience like for you incredible I
love working with other actors to be
honest so to get to work with so many
other actors was a real gift and
everyone was amazing I mean every time
David would text or call me and be like
so-and-so just signed up so-and-so just
signed up it just felt more and more
unbelievable and everyone was cool like
there wasn't there wasn't one bad egg in
the bunch everyone was cool everyone was
you know kind of like jumping on board
as you have to for a David or Russell
film you've got to dive in head first
and really go for it so we had a lot of
fun
uh and this is not just because I'm a
Canadian but Mike Myers is such a
standout for me he was almost
unrecognizable Romney you've obviously
worked with him in Bohemian Rhapsody can
we talk about what a scene stealer he is
I mean from the first time I met him it
was it was really just
tremendously difficult to compose
yourself because it just has you
cracking up on every take I learned that
a couple years ago and the same thing
happened on this film uh he came in with
this have you seen it yet yes the hair
everything well I'll tease it the sand
dance that might be one of my favorite
portions of this phone and he comes up
with that he goes David can I try this
out and required a costume and uh
production design and they whipped it up
like that but in this film you know
him and Michael Shannon are actually the
most unexpectedly hilarious dude
like would not I'm like trying to be
professional stuff I'm like but I
couldn't stop laughing like [ __ ] anytime
they talked about it they would just yo
going forward and we would send it and
we'd be like trying to hold it
like next level I've never done that
like when I kept cracking I've done a
crack up here and there then I can I can
refocus re-center right but every take
and it was different it was and they
were just bouncing off each other it was
bro it was a master class really an
improvisation yeah oh yeah and delivery
Kate is all that stuff
it's so funny John David calls an
All-Star Weekend yeah show up to set you
never know who's cut you're going to be
there but they're all bringing their a
game yeah yeah and I heard David say
this about the film he's like you know
it's a symphony of of actors who come in
and we'll create beautiful music
together but in all these movies that
were used to thing with green screens
and whatnot these performances and
personalities of the real special
effects in this film wow did you like I
love that that's very good okay no no
well I'm gonna throw this out there
obviously uh Margot and John David your
characters along with Christian Bale's
character make this packed uh so I was
curious who out of everyone you've
either worked at them in the past or
would love to work with in Hollywood
would you want to make a pact with that
you know would have your back no matter
what Romney you go first
me
yes Margo
oh Margo oh pressure's on now no I'm
I've he's right we we already have a
pact actually like have each other's
back for life we made that path we made
that pact already it's because we're
brother and sister in the film so
there's a there's we're tied by movie
Blood now yes there's a strong kinship
we developed immediately yes back
forever I also have John David
so I've had I've got that experience I
had an experience with the Adam Driver I
did a film with them a few years ago and
uh you know he's also in our film
and I feel like it was that kind of it
was that kind of thing you know we have
each other's back you know I felt that
I love that listen I had so much fun
watching this congratulations on the
movie so nice having all three of you
together in one room thank you